en eeuu la corte de suprema anuló la
histórica sentencia conocida como roe
versus wade que desde 1973 garantizaba
el derecho al aborto en todo el país
tras el fallo el presidente de bailén
criticó la sentencia asegurando que se
trata en un trágico error del tribunal
desde mismo viernes 24 de junio cuando
entró en vigencia esta norma varios
estados ya introdujeron prohibiciones en
el mapa que vamos a ver a continuación
vamos en rojo entonces los estados donde
fue penalizado inmediatamente o entrará
en vigor en 30 días como por ejemplo
texas al kansas y misurí en naranja los
que están a los estados que están
probablemente van a prohibir lo como lo
es arizona wisconsin florida en verde
los que tomaron medidas para protegerlo
como california nevada alaska hawai
nueva york maryland y en gris los que no
son claros al respecto unas 36 millones
de mujeres en edad reproductiva serán
privadas de este derecho al aborto que
en eeuu algún día fue un derecho federal
salvamos entonces ahora ser muñoz ella
es directora de la oficina de washington
del centro de derechos reproductivos
graciasaraceli por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 para hablar
sobre este tema cuáles son entonces las
implicaciones de esta medida el alcance
de esta medida que tomó la corte suprema
de eeuu
bueno el impacto más inmediato va a ser
a para aquellas personas que están
tratando de procurar un aborto ahora van
a tener que viajar miles de personas
miles de kilómetros para conseguir este
servicio de salud tan esencial y eso
indica también que van a tener que dejar
de ir a trabajar y no ser renumerado por
esos días de trabajo que van a poder
perder tener que hacer arreglos para
cuidado de sus familias y va a ser un
estrés económico y físico para estas
personas que quieren procurar este
servicio esencial ahora sé lo que va a
pasar también digamos que con este fallo
histórico nuevamente no debe anular el
fallo roe versus wade hay posibilidad de
poder revertirlo hay posibilidad que
ustedes vuelvan a la corte suprema-
pidiendo que se devuelva albert versus
wait
bueno no nos damos por vencidos te vamos
seguir luchando para proteger este
derecho tan esenciales del derecho
humano nuestra organización y otras
organizaciones de litigios estamos
ahorita revisando y preparando casos
para entablar en varias cortes para
proteger estas leyes en todos los
estados y así vamos a atacarle por ley
estado por estado para mantener las
clínicas abiertas por más tiempo posible
y pues claro en el futuro asegurar a
largo plazo que una mujer tiene el
derecho al aborto
digamos con este con este fallo del
tribunal supremo que buscan esto
realmente va a reducir los abortos en el
país
bueno nosotros sabemos por estudio tras
estudio y ejemplos que hemos visto en la
historia que estas leyes de penalización
no limitan ni paran a las personas que
quieren procurar un aborto solamente las
empuja a los márgenes a contextos
inseguros para recibir este servicio así
que esto no va a cambiar la necesidad ya
que el aborto es una parte de la salud
del cuidado de la salud es un retroceso
en los derechos civiles para las mujeres
o personas gestantes
sí claro el acceso al aborto que fue
asegurado bajo rock dio la oportunidad a
muchas mujeres tomar decisiones mejores
para ellas para sus futuros y para sus
familias ahora ya no tienen esa opción
ahora ya van a estar en una situación
donde pueden ser forzadas a mantener
lumbar a un embarazo no deseado así que
eso va a cambiar y como hemos dicho hay
estudios que demuestran el impacto
económico y físico no nada más a la
mujer sino a su comunidad y a la
sociedad
claro y también psicológicamente como
esto afectaría a las mujeres que
realmente desean interrumpir de una
forma o bajo sus decisiones digamos en
el embarazo y no lo pudieran hacer en su
estado también eso psicológicamente pues
tendría consecuencias de ustedes que han
podido identificar
bueno como he dicho hay muchos lugares o
hay muchas organizaciones que están
ayudando a mujeres a tratar de obtener
un servicio de agosto hay fondos de
aborto que ayudan a personas con
logísticas y económicamente y hay una
red de websites que tiene también
información donde uno puede conseguir un
aborto seguro y si es un impacto muy
grande para una persona tener que viajar
a otro estado como hemos dicho esa
persona ahora va a tener que faltar al
trabajo para perder un día tiene que
tener logísticas y eso pone en peligro a
las personas no nada más su salud pero
su situación personal y social claro
también en estos estados muchas mujeres
seguramente van a tener que recurrir a
clínicas de aborto clandestino como esto
también afecta la salud de las mujeres
si tiene un impacto a los sistemas de
salud también este porque esas mujeres
muchas veces corren peligro y va a ser
una
situación muy complicada y es una
situación muy complicada para estas
estas mujeres y sus familias
ahora también yéndonos un poco al tema
de los derechos civiles en general otras
comunidades como por ejemplo la
comunidad lgtb te tienen miedo a que
ocurra lo mismo con el avance con el
logro también que hicieron con el
matrimonio igualitario con una corte
suprema de mayoría conservadora
realmente
estas comunidades minoritarias peligran
también de un retroceso en lo que han
ganado el terreno de los derechos
civiles
si esta decisión pone en peligro otros
derechos esta decisión pone en peligro
el derecho al matrimonio
para personas del mismo sexo acceso a
anticonceptivos
decisiones familiares íntimas este esta
decisión promulgó un marco
este que solamente reconoce derechos
establecidos antes de la ratificación
del 14 mandamiento de la constitución de
los eeuu en asia de
1868 y como consecuencia muchos de los
derechos que hoy conocemos están en
peligro como ser para proteger sus
derechos ahora sí bueno muchas cosas que
todavía podemos hacer como hemos dicho
nuestra organización y otras
organizaciones del egipcio van a seguir
entablando casos pero también hay una
solución federal este hay la posibilidad
de pasar una ley federal que proteja los
derechos de la mujer acceder a servicios
de aborto así que por gente puede llamar
a su senador y pedir que voten por esa
ley y sus siglas en inglés es web
también uno puede es de apoyar fondos de
aborto que ayudan a personas conseguir
este servicio esencial
y pueden también comunicar con sus
comunidades y sus familiares y también
decir la importancia de este derecho
así que hay muchas cosas que uno puede
hacer para impulsar cloro y preservar
este derecho